c'est pour toi yuda je te souhaite un
bon anniversaire au total c'est une
promesse cette bague en est le symbole
une fois qu'on sera grand je voudrais
qu'on se marie toi et moi
toi j'aime mieux ça quand on sera grand
je voudrais les cancers
[Musique]
tu est frappé d'une malédiction
elle pourrait sauver des vies si tu
savais l'utiliser correctement je peux
plus risqué de faire de mal à qui que ce
soit avant il faut que tu apprennes à
maîtriser sa puissance pas la peine de
relancer à vivre il est trop tôt pour en
arriver là c'est pas pour s'amuser à
devenir ami avec l'un d'entre eux sur ce
bonne chance et tâcher de revenir en vie
pour briser une malédiction il faut
d'abord apprendre à mieux les comprendre
pourquoi tu as voulu s'inscrire dans
notre école
qu'est ce que tu fais ici allez répond
c'est quoi ton objectif rigueur tu
m'entends oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya j'ai
besoin de ta force
[Musique]
à mes yeux l'amour et le plus tordu des
fléaux
[Musique]
ça va donc être à moi de te feront t
personne ne fait de mal à utah
[Musique]
combat sera sans pitié on verra quelles
qu'en sortira vainqueur
viens m'aider je